alright you're done let's look at the
solution okay we'll begin by adding a
log tag into our abstract threaded sync
adapter since this stuff runs in the
background it's helpful to have some
logging since we ultimately want the
sync adapter to run in an unattended
mode we pull the location query from our
utility class and then we pasting the
code from our existing sunshine service
we'll have to patch a few things up
we'll have to call get contacts to get
the current context for example we copy
over the get weather data from json
function as well as the add location
function finally we fix update whether
to use our sync adapter